I mean there's borderline personality
influencers that's a that's a genre of
the internet now there are people that
are getting clout based on the
exploration of their borderline
personality disorder and then there's
people that don't have borderline
personality disorder convincing
themselves that they do I know a guy on
Instagram he's an eczema influencer I
kid you not he's a hot guy
he's a hot dude on IG and he has eczema
and he just pulls his hand out and he
goes a lot of people don't know what
eczema is or a lot of people confuse
eczema with something else and a lot of
people are just like hey man why is your
hand up it's like dude just put
cream on it the rest of you is fine what
is this